bonjour à tous je sais pas si vous avez
vu cette image c'est une pancarte qui
apparut au canada et à peu près un mois
et ça fait un grand pôle et à cause de
la faute d'orthographe
donc ça fait le tour des journaux
référencement en 2 millions de reste 2
millions de référencement de google
quasiment tous les journaux en ont parlé
il ya même des politiciens qui vous fait
pression pour remplacer la pancarte et
un ami m'a montré cette image en me
disant que vraiment la nouvelle
génération bas sacré l'orthographe et ça
me fait doucement rire parce que dans
mon pays en inde le massacre de
l'orthographe ça donne ça donc si vous
allez en un attention pouvait avoir une
surprise sur vos clients si vous allez
en inde et que vous commandez du thé
précisé que vous voulez sous forme
liquide
apparemment il ya une autre forme je les
connais pas encore et aussi si vous
allez en inde pas de vol à l étalage
surtout pas la justice va pas vous pour
suivre et vous fera autre chose
et ces images qui sont au fond assez
anodine et représente assez bien
deux aspects linguistiques que j'ai dans
mon pays on a ce qu'on appelle le moins
une baffe et le potlatch ebace le mans
ebace c'est les langues maternelles
notre héritage culturel linguistique ou
pour moi c'était une langue indienne le
camp caennais et pour vous c'est le
français ya aussi notre langue le
potache ebace qui est la langue du
ventre est là pour vous comme pour moi
et comme pour les gens qui ont écrit
cette entente car tu es bien c'est
l'anglais est ce que je voudrais aborder
avec vous aujourd'hui c'est justement le
fait que ces potaches ebace ces langues
du ventre l'anglais ont tendance à saint
pée réalisé aux dépens des langues
minoritaires qui sont dans mon cas le
camp caennais après quand on pense
disparition voilà à peu près tout ce
qu'on a en tête un panda scolaires des
récifs coralliens
mais on oublie tous cette diversité
linguistique qui est pourtant la plus en
danger
faut savoir que le panda et les récifs
coralliens par exemple on en parle assez
souvent et souvent des sommets sur la
peau la pollution par exemple et l'ours
polaire est quasiment sauvé d'affaires
par contre semble faire de mauvais jeu
de mots pour les diversité linguistique
c'est mort toutes les toutes les lans
qui disparaissent disparaissent de
manière irréversible
en ce moment ma mère m'aime à l'heure où
je vous parle il ya une langue qui
disparaît toutes les deux semaines
quand vous êtes né il y avait peu à peu
près 7000 langues sur terre quand vous
mourrez
il leur restera plus que six ans dans
plus de 90% du patrimoine culturel
linguistique sera parti et si vous en
parle si ça me tient particulièrement à
coeur c'est parce que je viens de là un
petit territoire
un petit état en inde qui s'appelle goa
ou et parler le camp cagnois c'est une
ancienne colonie portugaise mais qui a
été indienne musulmanes sous domination
musulmane arabe perse ensuite
britanniques puis rues indiennes pur
portugaise est là depuis trente ans et
les deux yeux
l'indienne et de ce choc des mondes
moyen-orient orient et occident est née
une langue le camp cani qui est un peu
le reflet de tout ça et c'est donc en
constante évolution il ya même du
français qui est en train de s'insérer
dans ce jeu vous avec mes parents par
exemple
donc mes parents me parle d'un mélange
de kangani et de français et par exemple
dans ma langue grain de riz se dit shit
c'est toujours marrant de voir ma mère
proposé aux invités des plats cheat
mais après tout pourquoi ça l'est encore
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de
préserver ces langues c'est vrai vous
parler le français c'est plutôt ça va
pas disparaître au dernier aux dernières
nouvelles ça a failli disparaître
et après tout remplacer des langues
minoritaires par des langues majoritaire
ça faciliterait les échanges auraient
moindre malentendu plus d'entente entre
les pays et bien justement non ce que je
voudrais vous faire comprendre
aujourd'hui est vraiment transmettre
c'est que la diversité linguistique est
à sa façon aussi importante que la
diversité biologique et là ça peut
paraître assez difficile à concevoir
c'est vrai comment est-ce que des mots
peuvent être aussi important que des
espèces que des êtres vivants et bien
d'abord si les langues soit si
importante c'est parce qu'elle soit une
bibliothèque d'informations qui ont été
collectées par nos ancêtres des milliers
d'observations qui sont contenus dans la
lande est transmise par la tradition
orale notamment sur des plantes
médicinales par exemple et ça certains
pays dont très bien compris par exemple
en australie il ya pas si longtemps que
ça
il ya une épidémie du lsa qui a résisté
aux traitements usuels
il a fallu qu'une infirmière
franchissent la barrière de la langue
allez voir les landes les tribus
aborigènes locales pour trouver une
plante médicinale qui a un peu sauvé
tout ce peuple
voilà un intérêt concret de la
sauvegarde des langues qui est qu'il ya
enfin l'australie a lancé un vaste
programme
suite à cet incident donc les programmes
de sauvegarde ça c'est quoi c'est
concrètement référencer des mots
qu'avait créé des dictionnaires traduire
en masse et ça se fait à toutes les
échelles par exemple en ce moment même
des étudiants unsa sont en train de
traduire facebook en breton donc voilà
les langues ça définit en fait une
bibliothèque d'informations mais ça va
plus loin
chaque langue définit une culture on ça
paraît assez évident à dire des chinois
par le par les juifs les chinois par le
chinois mais ça paraît assez évident
mais là aussi il faut comprendre que
chaque mot influent sur notre manière de
penser sur notre perception du monde et
c'est aussi je vais vous donner un
exemple très simple
et pour ça je vous propose d'aller en
namibie je paye pas les biens par
exemple en france
vous connaissez une dizaine de gamme de
couleurs et depuis tout petit on vous a
appris à différencier le bleu
du jaune du rouge et votre esprit a
réussi à créer une frontière nette entre
plusieurs couleurs parfois des gammes de
longueurs d'onde proches comme le jaune
et l'orangé et bien sachez que ses
gammes de longueurs d'onde ses
frontières ne sont pas pareils par
exemple les himba en namibie en namibie
ont seulement cinq grandes gammes de
longueurs d'onde maintenant regardez
autour de vous regardez vous voyez quoi
comme couleur on du noir mais
concrètement vous verrez quoi du jaune
du rouge du vert et bien les himbas y
verrait du don bout du tombeau du double
ou un peu de sous
et après ce que vous allez me dire c'est
sûrement que c'est simplement des
désignations différentes et qu'au fond
on voit la même chose
eh bien non des batteries tests ont
prouvé le contraire et je vous propose
de refaire ces tests si vous montre cet
ensemble de carrie et que je vous
demande de me trouver un intrus je pense
que vous voyez tous le même un carré
bleu et d'un mba ne le verrez pas
justement parce qu'une incapacité
l'incapacité linguistique à différencier
le bleu du vert a entraîné une
incapacité à différencier ces deux
couleurs
maintenant on refait le test avec ça si
je vous demande de différencier de
trouver un intrus quelqu'un peut me non
c'est normal et bien imba le verrez tout
de suite parce que justement ils ont
plus de mots pour décrire ces couleurs
qui sont à la frontière du jaune c'est
toutes ces nuances de vert qui sont à la
frontière du jaune et donc là ils vont
un carré qui tire légèrement vers le
vert pomme
parce qu'ils ont plus de mots pour ses
nuances les fameuses fiches stic est
devenu vous connaissez tous
donc la longue influent sur notre
perception du monde sur la perception
des couleurs mais ça va plus loin même
la syntaxe des mots influent sur notre
façon de mémoriser par exemple pour ça
je vous propose d'aller en amérique
donc si je vous demande de décrire cette
image vous me dites quoi un homme fait
tomber un vase
je pense c'est la manière la plus simple
en france est de le dire et là dont
désolé de vous rappeler des mauvais
souvenirs de français mais dans la
syntaxe
on voit un lien de causalité le fautif
un homme fait tomber un vase résultat
est bien cette syntaxe
elle n'est pas pareil partout il n'y a
pas besoin d'aller très loin pour le
voir par exemple en en espagnol la façon
la plus idiomatique de décrire cette
image ce serait ces longs bio elle
frôlait vous désolé pour l'accent le
vase s'est cassé et là tout de suite on
voit plus le lien de causalité
eh bien ça influe là sur la mémorisation
des batteries de tests vous prouver que
quand vous et quand montrer cette image
à 10,10 panique et des francophones et
bien les hispaniques avaient plus de mal
à se souvenir que c'est un homme qui
s'est trompé de base ça aurait pu être
le vent le fameux enfants bref voilà la
langue influe aussi sur notre manière de
penser le monde notre de différentes
approches du monde et c'est bien le
thème de ce toc c'est le latéral finkin
les différentes façons de penser le
monde
et si ces différentes cultures si toutes
ces langues
donc ces différentes cultures sont en
danger sa cause de sa non pas à cause
d'einstein ma cause de l'anglais qui a
une tendance à saint pée réalisé aux
dépens des autres langues
après je critique absolument pas
l'anglais de sa d'un point de vue de sa
culture de sa richesse mais plus sur le
fait que c'est devenu de nos jours une
barrière discriminante
je pense que vous connaissez tous le
principe take it off hull
si on la sait très bien si on l'apaba ne
peut pas rentrer dans certaines grandes
universités
dites vous qu'il ya cent ans einstein
n'a pu rentrer dans l'école
polytechnique de zurich
cent ans plus tard ils pourraient pas
rentrer dans de très bonnes écoles
justement comines ça parce que les
dyslexiques et qu'il avait un angle
assez limité donc voilà un siècle plus
tard juste à cause d'une langue qui a pu
se propager à vitesse folle et dont
on utilise mal eh bien on arrive à ça
finalement tout ce que je viens de vous
dire se résume en une question très
terrestre est très simple est ce que
vous voulez que vous et vos enfants
viviez dans un monochromatique ou est ce
que vous voulez vivre dans un océan dans
un arc en ciel de culture humaine c'est
vraiment à vous de voir
pour finir ce toc je sais que d'habitude
on dit merci on s'en va mais je vais
faire mieux cette fois je vais vous
apprendre à dire merci dans ma langue
natale du robot l'école